we've already seen that we can
categorize triangles as being
equilateral isosceles or scalene based
on the lengths of the sides of the
triangle so if none of the lengths are
congruent so if you have something
something like this
we would consider this scaling i'm
assuming that this side is not equal to
that side and neither of these are equal
to that side so that would be scalene
and this is all a review if i have at
least two of the sides being equal so
say let's say that side is the same
length as that side right over there we
could call this so i'll mark it off as
these are the same length this would be
an isosceles
isosceles
triangle and then if all three of them
all three sides are congruent
so if all three sides are congruent if
all three sides are the same length we
would call this equilateral
equilateral and in most circles you
could also say this is isosceles because
isosceles would be at least two sides
being equal so this one definitely has
at least two sides it has all three so
this is you could say equilateral and
isosceles while this one if we assume
this third side is a different length
this would just be isosceles not
equilateral now all of that is review
now what i want to think about in this
video is what if we're not given the
lengths of the sides and what if we're
just given a few of the angles so for
example
let's say we were given a triangle
let's say that we were given a triangle
where we're given
where we're given a few of the angle
measures
so let's say we are told that this angle
right over here is
i don't know let's say this angle right
over here is 40 degrees and this angle
right over here
is 50 degrees
now based on that could you somehow
classify this as scalene isosceles or
equilateral well the key here to realize
is if you know two angles two interior
angles of a triangle you can always
figure out the third because the three
need to add up to 180 degrees so this is
40 that is 50
so these two add up to 90. so to add up
to 180 degrees this one must be a 90
degree angle we can even mark it we can
even mark it as a right angle
and so if you have a triangle where all
of the interior angles are different
that means that all of the side lengths
are going to be different and one way to
think about it is this if this angle
became wider if this angle became wider
this length let me actually show the
corresponding so this angle if this if
that angle right over there became wider
then this length would have to become
wider
if this angle became larger or smaller
then this side is going to have to
become larger or smaller and if this
angle became larger or smaller then this
side is going to become larger and
smaller so hopefully you see in a pre
you appreciate that if you have three
different angles you're going to have
three different side lengths so just
based on the angles here that we have
three different angles we can say that
this is going to be
a scalene
a scalene triangle
now we can look at a couple other
examples what if we knew
what if we knew that
what if we knew let's do an interesting
one
what if
this angle actually let me let's say
this angle is
let's say this angle right over here is
i don't know let's say it is 70 degrees
and let's say this angle over here is
40 degrees
now based on the information i've given
you what kind of triangle is this going
to be or can you even figure it out
well we use the same idea the interior
angles need to add up to 180
70 plus 40 is 110 so you could say 110
plus what is equal to
180 degrees well this is going to have
to be 70 degrees so this angle right
over here is 70 degrees and so now we
have a scenario where two of the angles
have the same measure
and so this angle
is really one way to think about it
based on whether this angle is large or
small it's going to
find the length of that side
and this angle right over here depending
on how large or small it is it's going
to define the length on this side
and so because these two angles are
congruent because they have the same
measure their opposite sides are going
to be congruent so this is going to be
the same as that and so just based on
the information i had started giving you
if you if because you can show that two
angles are going to be the same you can
say that this is going to be an
isosceles
triangle
and now let's do a third example and you
could probably guess what i'm going to
do in this third example
if i can
if i have
let's say this angle is 60 degrees this
angle is 60 degrees what type of a
triangle is this going to be
well if this is 60 this is 60 to make
them add up to 180 this would have to be
60 that would have to be 60 degrees as
well and if you have all of the angles
are congruent then that means that all
of the sides are congruent and so now
you are dealing with an equilateral now
as we said before this is also you could
view this as a subset of isosceles
because you have at least two angles and
you have two sides being congruent but
here it's all three so this is an
equilateral triangle